marlins have lost seven straight games
and taiwan walker will try and make it
eight but wants to finish on a strong
note uh facing a team that i think is
free swingers and hopefully his pitches
especially that foot finger change work
to his advantage
and walker strikes out rojas to start
the night that was the slider that he
could not find in boston watch how sharp
this is and the downward movement he had
a real sweeper working at fenway park
that's just the opposite chisholm at
first 22 stolen bases this year
grounded down at third vr has to back
off it
baez with a good pickup and he turns the
double play man javi baez does it again
this time turns an offbeat throw into a
five four three double play said eliezer
hernandez in his 11th start of the
season coming off kind of a mixed bag
against the washington nationals he had
a season high seven strikeouts but also
allowed three home runs
and a ground ball maggie's there over to
jazz and on to first both starters get a
double play ball in the first inning
sanchez takes a call third strike and
the uh the glare out of the pitch
doesn't work so well on that pitch that
was beautiful started right at his knee
ended up over the middle plate it even
got the approval of sanchez
and brinson chases the slider for strike
three so walker looking sharp early
that's his third strikeout eliezer ready
for an 0-2 to the met's first baseman
and he goes to the slider for the
strikeout that's his first of the night
one away know this is the good slider
and this is the one you like to see that
fools hitters both and how it moves
across the strike zone and the lack of
velocity
he gets jonathan vr second strikeout of
the inning once again the slider and
there are two way yeah in a lot of ways
acting like a changeup look at vr he too
way out in front
two balls two strikes two outs man on
second and there it is another strikeout
on the slider three in the inning and he
works around the double
the o2
breaking ball on a pitch in the dirt
strike three de la cruz couldn't hold
his swing
walker got him to fight on the slider
you know strikeout for taiwan walker two
outs it is seinfeld night at citi field
how are you guys doing it's good to see
you good to see you
you're holding up well i'm glad we got
you here before the end of the year
michael conforto stands in grounded into
a double play his first time
[Applause]
that's fantastic and he had another ball
in his club anyway
that's the greatest you see that little
kid oh my god i love that
i mean you bring your glove how many
times do you have to bring it
every time yeah
you know
i mean i went to 500 games as a kid i
call one ball wow
you know you keep bringing the glove and
every once in a while right i mean
a bomb that is a long home run straight
away gary get the uh exit velo on that
ball would you by the way 469 feet on
that home run
wow four six nine you really have no
idea how much joy you bring us fans
you're the best still the best booth in
the game
take us to break okay
all right we're gonna break but we're
coming back with the mets
three-two swung on and missed strike
three good splitter there from taiwan
walker puts together a one two three top
of the fifth now nobody on which to
dominic smith domino is one to center
chasing de la cruz back it's over his
head and it hops up over the wall for a
ground rule double now two outs as
taiwan walker will bat
pulled over the back nice play by diaz
up to his feet close play safe
walker beat it out it's a nice play by
the young first baseman let's see if he
beat it he hustled down that line
he beat it that's up runners at the
corners with two out for brandon nemo
nemo flies one along the left field line
that may fall in and it does for a base
hit
smith in the score walker to third a fly
ball double for brandon nimmo and the
mets lead two nothing
first time since 2017 the taiwan walker
has thrown a pitch in the eighth inning
this one's going to go toward the gap
hold that thought for just one second it
gets down cut off by conforto lewin's on
his way to second and he will
get there with a double and you wonder
how much longer luis rojas goes with
taiwan walker here
that's outside for ball four and that's
going to probably
get louie up there third walk given up
by walker who knows what to expect next
he doesn't want to turn around to see
what's coming out well that's the end of
taiwan walker's season his last start
and it was a brilliant one
seth lugo worked a 1-2-3 inning last
night back for moore with a couple of
men on in the eighth
this one's out to center field pretty
well hit nemo turns and that's going to
one-hop the wall
lewin diaz coming in to score they will
hold the trail runner alvarez
an rbi double for alex jackson and the
marlins are within a run here in the
eighth and now nick fortes to pinch hit
here and fortes went around strike three
nick strikeout for lugo two-man down
for miguel rojas miggy into right
that'll fall in for a base hit sierra
coming around third he'll score rojas to
second
he's out but the two-run score and the
marlins take a 3-2 lead quiet all night
long against taiwan walker but they find
a way in the eighth 3-2
marlins in front
swinging a miss and de la cruz down on
strikes for the first down 0-2 to
sanchez
and he waves at one for strike three so
back-to-back strikeouts for loop after
the lead-off hit
it's driven out to left center back in
the gap goes pillar and who won it down
to end the inning another scoreless
inning for aaron luke take another notch
off that era we go to the bottom of the
night meds down by a run here's baez who
doubled back in the second since then
has struck out and hit a comebacker into
a double play here it comes from floro
he does climb the ladder and he gets the
strikeout two away
well it's up to buddy vr floral home
with a 2-2 pitch swing and a miss for
strike three
it's a marlins win
bats silent through the first seven
innings tonight against taiwan walker
but they find a way in the eighth inning
to make some noise and they come from
behind to win it 3-2